chrissy teigen mourns the loss of her
dog putty sporty spice might not be
invited to the royal wedding like we
thought plus Lance Bass on the upcoming
NSYNC reunion
hey guys Denny here now the last thing I
want to do on this show is hit you with
some sad news but I had to share Chrissy
Teigen beautiful tribute to her beloved
dog putty now if you follow Chrissy on
snapchat or are one of her sixteen point
three million followers on Instagram
that you know who I'm talking about she
and John got putty in their first year
of dating and Chrissy shared how he was
literally there for everything
Chrissy posted a series of pics of her
precious dog and her caption damn near
broke my heart she wrote in part we are
their entire lives and is the greatest
shame that they can only bless us with a
short spot of time in ours I always knew
I would lose a piece of me when he left
us I feel the hole now I'm not crying
you're crying
Chrissy who is expecting her second
child also wrote how putty loved on new
babies and new bellies and here's the
proof look at this video of putty loving
up on Luna when she was just a little
baby peanut Chrissy also revealed putty
is survived by her other dog Pippa and
that they were married like they
literally had an entire ceremony that's
John putty and Pippa alright you guys
they might want to consider pulling a
Barbara Streisand and getting Pippa and
their other dog Pablo's genes taken so
they can clone them later
just as an option so I'm saying anyway I
thought Chrissy's posts were sweet but
let's move on to something spicy looks
like that Spice Girls reunion is still
up in the air I mean what a saga
really shall we recap first the group
selfie the first time all five girls had
been together for a photo in six years
and that immediately ignited speculation
over the possibility of new music and a
tour
well then Victoria Beckham reportedly
shut that down and now mal C aka sporty
spice is echoing her words telling the
son quotes its very early stages we're
not talking about new music or going out
on the road together at this time
as for whether they'll be performing at
that Royal Wedding well it looks like
Mel C might not be invited as Mel B
suggested last week what did you get an
invitation what was spot 5 Spice Girls
if so they invited all the Spice Girls
to the Royal Wedding yeah you bet that's
Mel B she seems to know more about you
than me
fans like me are still holding out for a
Spice Girls reunion and performance at
Harry and Megan's main nuptials though a
source told eat see at the time there is
not plans for them to perform at the
wedding as for those reports claiming
Victoria has backed away from hitting
the road a source told et today that she
hasn't pulled out of anything adding
quote the girls are all getting on
incredibly well are united and all
excited about the reunion the tour has
always been media speculation well to me
it looks like something is definitely
brewing and who knows maybe Megan Marco
pulled at Beyonce and the girls had to
sign a nondisclosure and now no one
wants to say anything I don't know
trying to find out for you guys we'll
just have to wait and see come May 19
when Prince Harry and Megan tied the
knot now a reunion that will take place
the fellas of NSYNC Justin Timberlake
may not have shared the Superbowl stage
with his former bandmates but Lance Bass
teased 2et we'll be getting that reunion
sooner than you think
we're reuniting very soon we're uh we're
getting our star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame
it's so weird they won't let us tell the
date but it's really soon but yeah we're
all getting together since the VMAs
it'll be the first time that we're all
together the good news that in sync fans
want to hear we'll just have to wait
alright well thanks for watching today
guys we'll be back tomorrow and in the
meantime give this video a little like
and comment if you got something to say
are you excited about the in secret
union I know I am I want to know okay
bye bye bye